i think i'll do a fart room like tonight
or something
yeah i'll i'll join hell yeah
he's got some good farts
let him rip tonight dude
yeah you know it's fart room time let's
go
oh that was a good one let me let me
announce wait is that allowed can we say
can we say
verbally what we think of the farts
after oh yeah yeah it's like i have a
judging panel
okay it could be that could be fun
uh let's talk about this um these sexy
ass joe biden pictures
oh yeah can we pull those up luke
these are hot dude you ready to get
turned on
i mean i i i've already uh
i've already had to like ban myself from
looking at it
because the you know the images are just
too
oh yes it's
too attractive you're looking good man
these are so obviously photoshopped
right
yeah i mean i'll say it a million times
those are definitely not his hips
those are not his hips bro dude's
packing too man
dude look at that like like fupa fold
right there
yeah he's he's bricked up is he
he might be breaked up
[Laughter]
he's like acid washed jeans like isn't
he 90 years old
yeah like it looks weird does it not
it does and he his body's in a state
where if you're
to support it on one ankle like that
it'd be
something serious that's how we know
this is photoshopped oh that's not what
you tweeted you said yeah
but like i'm just like i need to get out
my system like i feel like i haven't
been able to say this
anywhere really but there's no way
that's the biggest
tale of it all if they had him standing
there on two feet that would have been
some old ass [ __ ] i've been like yeah
yep that's him but the one foot i think
is what really takes me out of it it
breaks reality for me
what's with the is it a it's a golf club
what kind of
golfing outfit is this yeah i don't know
yeah
golfing and cuffed jeans that seems like
miserable don't you like you're
awful i mean just sweat dripping out of
your
big clearly his big ball sack or
something
yeah aren't like golfing pants like kind
of loose like
doesn't doesn't tiger like hasn't he
golfed in like a probation hearing
outfit for his whole career
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think golfing and jeans
don't usually golfing shorts
i thought like tiger had like those big
baggy pants hold on
i thought golfers in general
yeah you golfing big kyle just chatted
you golfing pants
yes golfing pants that's what i meant
but all right i uh i golf before i've
golfed before i know that
i'm go i'm look up professional golfers
swagger in chief is it are these real or
are we getting [ __ ] with
probably getting probably getting
pranked swagger in chief
yeah that can't be real
from double denim to peak preppy
oh that's not about number 46 gets our
big fit makeover
go back to the first one again
it's so funny all right i'm kind of an
outfit
isn't it sorry i just have to say i'm
completely misremembering
tiger's outfits no he had he always had
like the sleek nike outfits
yeah yeah these shits are fitted these
are not
um baggy by any means i just thought
yeah anyway
um
yeah this like two-tone james charles
outfit right here
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's kind of a teddy
fresh type outfit a little bit yeah
yeah i should say teddy fresh i don't
want i don't want to
reignite the beef my bad
[Laughter]
this color paneled outfit
dude looks like a [ __ ] like a swatch
book for couches
yeah yeah totally he does
oh [ __ ] i know everyone looks at this
and he's like
he joe biden doesn't even know why he's
there
kind of true he probably doesn't know he
doesn't even know
i don't even know why he took these
pictures
so what are we doing here you're the
president right
right that's what this desk is
presidential who's the president you are
i am right
i love the starbucks yeah
dude stop it can he drink anything with
one hand
that's the biggest sign of old is you
need both
you need both feet both hands yeah
you're not just like picking [ __ ] up off
the counter anymore
[Laughter]
bro what what if as soon as they took
this picture
they're like that was great and then his
grip just completely goes and then
coffee is the [ __ ]
he's definitely not holding anything
they photoshop that in he's just
yeah make it like your grip and
something
okay but don't photoshop anything weird
into this
dude they position him like this they
get the shot and then they're like we
got it and he just falls over
because he can't balance coffee hits
yeah that's mean old people falling down
isn't funny
sort of a little bit yeah it is a little
bit
except you said do that that grandpa
that got attacked and
oh bro oh terrible [ __ ]
he got killed right yeah this is like he
was 70 something years old and now
and then the same guy attacked two other
seniors there's a whole
that same day yeah there's a there's a
whole
you know controversy behind that it's
not even controversy it's just like
[ __ ] up dude
yeah socioeconomic [ __ ] that is just
not this bummer
what someone attacking old people yeah
it's just it's just like a
kind of a psycho thing isn't it i mean i
guess there's just been like a history
of like elderly like
asian oh yeah i was reading that on
twitter being like attacked on
in the bay area and stuff and just
brutal
like hate crimes yeah
jesus christ damn bro you did a kid cudi
what yeah i just dropped that yeah what
about that dude who got murdered
you see the old guy that got murdered
what i don't like that
yeah sorry about that it was a little
bit dark but i was reading that last
night
oh
i said something on stream the other day
and the whole chat was like well you're
scaring the hoes away and that [ __ ]
had me rolling
three thousand people saying you're
scaring the hose away
yeah dude stop dude stop the girls are
leaving man
what did you say i don't even know what
the [ __ ] i was joking about i said
something and
i just started like riffing and people
were like dude you're scaring the hoes
away
that's funny
you